in this video you're going to learn how
to tell whether an equation represents y
as a function of X and we're going to go
through seven examples together so let's
dive into this video so first of all
what exactly does that mean is why a
function of X well there's a couple
different ways to look at this but one
way is that for every x value which the
X's are the inputs there's only one y
value you don't want to have for example
if x is one y be negative 8 and if x is
1 y be negative 6 you'd have one input
going to more than one output I like to
think about that as being unpredictable
like if you type something into your
computer and one time it opens this
program one time it opens a different
program you're not going to know what's
going to happen it's like unpredictable
so
for every x value there's only going to
be one y value the other way to look at
it is if you can graph the function like
if you know what the function looks like
you can do what they call the vertical
line test and the reason the vertical
line test works is because it's saying
okay for this x value if it only crosses
the graph at most once you know then
that just tells you that there's one y
value where if for example the graph
looked like this and you do the vertical
line test you'd say oh for a given x
value I'm getting more than one y value
and again we're back to that sort of
unpredictable nature there meaning
there's more than one output for a given
input so you'll see how this works as we
go through some of these problems but
for number one
when you're given an equation I think
sometimes the easiest way to do it is
either to graph it or solve for y so
what I mean by that is get y by itself
so we're going to try to isolate this y
by working from the outside in I'm going
to subtract 2x squared from both sides
of the equation
okay so that gives us y squared is equal
to 1 minus 2x squared and now instead of
squaring I'm going to take the square
root of both sides because the square
and the square root those are inverses
but remember when you yourself take the
square root of both sides you get two
answers
positive or negative the square root of
1 minus 2x squared now you're probably
saying Mario how does that help me well
what you can do is you can test this out
you could say like hmm if I put in an x
value say for example zero
0 squared is zero two times zero is zero
one minus 0 is 1 right and then the
square root of 1 is 1 but then we have
plus or minus 1. so what that tells me
is that when X was 0 I got one
and negative 1. so for a given input I'm
going getting more than one output so
that tells me that Y is not a function
of X so for this one we're going to say
no
okay let's look at another one so for
number two now
we've got this equation 3x squared plus
Y is equal to 6. so again the question
is is y a function of X well let's go
ahead and do like we did over here let's
solve for y
by getting it by itself so we're going
to subtract 3x squared from both sides
and so that gives us y equals negative
3x squared plus 6. now you're probably
familiar with quadratic equations and
this is a parabola that's opening
downward and it's being shifted up six
so you can see
it would look something roughly
like this so you could do your vertical
line test and say okay as I go across
the graph with a vertical line does it
cross the graph more than once ever no
like if I draw a vertical line here
across this just at one point if I draw
a vertical line here just one point if I
draw a vertical line like that just one
point so that tells me for every x value
I'm just getting one y value
and that tells me that yes Y is indeed a
function of x
you can also do it using the little test
Point method that I was doing earlier
here like I could say if x is 0 then Y
is equal to six so I'm saying if I have
an input I'm only getting one output you
can kind of test it like that
okay for number three now what do you
think for this one we've got Y is equal
to the absolute value of x plus two
you're probably familiar with absolute
value graphs
and Transformations remember when it's
grouped with the X like this it has the
opposite effect so the plus two will
actually shift the graph a left to
and so your graph would look something
like that and so now if you do your
vertical line test you can see okay yeah
it's only crossing the graph at most
once as I scan across like that so in
this case yes Y is a function of X and
again you can also do it like testing
some inputs some X values you could say
if x is 0 y equals absolute value of 2
which is just two we're just getting one
output let's take a look at a few more
examples okay if you feel like you're
getting the hang of this go ahead and
pause the video and see if you can do
these last four examples here and test
yourself but we'll go through them
together as well
so for number four what do you think on
this one the absolute value of y is
equal to X plus 2 is y a function of x
well
again you can graph this if you know
what the graph looks like and do the
vertical line test or you can try
solving for y getting y by itself
or you can even do the test Point method
which we mentioned earlier where we can
pick some values for X like for example
if I put 0 in for X that's going to be
the absolute value of y is equal to 2
which means that y could be positive 2.
the absolute value is 2 or the absolute
value of a negative 2 would be 2. so
what that's telling us is for a given x
value 0 y could be positive 2 or
negative 2 and you can see that we have
in one input going to more than one
output so Y is not a function of X so
let's go ahead and say no for this one
okay for number five now what do you
think for this one y is equal to 3x plus
1 is y a function of x
well this one you're probably familiar
with it's just a line see how it's in
the slope intercept form the Y equals MX
plus b form it crosses the Y intercept
at one it has a slope of three so that
means we're going rise three run one
and our line would look something like
that now if we do our vertical line test
and we scan across you can see it's a
crossing the graph at most once for each
of those vertical lines which tells us
that yes
Y is a function of x
okay how about for number six what did
you get on this One X Plus y to the
fourth is equal to 16.
well
if I was going to do this one I'm not
familiar with what the graph looks like
necessarily but I can solve for y so
let's go ahead and get the Y by itself
by subtracting X from both sides
then I'm going to take the fourth root
of both sides so instead of the fourth
power take the fourth root those are
inverses but whenever you take the even
root of both sides of the equation you
get two answers plus or minus so this is
going to be plus or minus the fourth
root of negative X Plus 16.
and now I would do some test points I'd
say well let me see if x is equal to
zero
that's the fourth root of 16 which is
two but it's plus or minus two so you
can see for a given input we're getting
more than one output so in this case no
Y is not a function of x
and before we do this last problem if
you like the way that I explain things
check out my video courses for sale my
algebra 1 and my algebra 2 slash college
algebra video courses for sale I take
you through a typical course and I go
into a lot of explanations and a lot of
practice problems and it's a good
adjunct to whatever you're learning in
your class or if you're doing
independent study or you just want to
review so check those out but for this
last question number seven what do you
think about this one is why a function
of x
well you probably recognize this as the
standard form of the equation of a
circle it has a center at positive 2
negative three so let's draw a little
graph here positive 2 negative threes or
Center and this is your radius squared
but the square root of one is just one
so you go up one left one down one right
one so it's basically a circle right and
you can see that this is actually
failing the vertical line test for a
given x value there's more than one y
value so we could stop there and say no
or if you don't like that option or
you're not familiar with this equation
you could always try to solve for y
what's going to happen and you can kind
of visualize this is if you subtract
this group to the other side and then to
get the Y by itself you're going to have
to take the square root of both sides
which we've been talking about in
previous problems you get two answers
plus or minus so you can see that you're
going to get more than one output for y
so great job if you're able to follow
all these different examples if you want
to see more and just test yourself or
practice more check out another video I
did talking about is why a function of X
right there and I'll see over in that
video